michael saylor you said before there's
no second best to bitcoin
what would be the second best
traditionally there's ethereum with
smart contracts cardano with proof of
stake
polka dot with uh interoperability
between blockchains dochecoin has the
incredible power of the meme
uh
privacy with monero that just can keep
going there's the there's of course
after the uh
block size wars
uh the different
offshoots of bitcoin i think if you if
you decompose or segment the crypto
market you've got crypto property
bitcoin is the king of that you know and
other bitcoin forks that want to be an
you know a bearer instrument store of
value
like would be a property a bitcoin cash
or litecoin something like that
then you've got crypto
currencies
i don't think i don't think bitcoin's a
currency because uh a currency i define
in nation states since
a currency is an a digital asset that
you can transfer as a
you know in a transaction without
incurring a taxable obligation
so that means has to be a stable dollar
or a stable euro or a stable yen a
stable coin so i think you've got crypto
currencies tether circle most famous
then i think you've got crypto platforms
you know and ethereum is the most famous
of the crypto platforms the platform
upon which you know with smart contract
functionality
etc
and then i think you've got just crypto
securities it's just like my favorite
whatever meme coin and i love it because
i love it and it's attached to my game
or my company or my persona or my
whatever
i think if you if you
you know pushed me
and said what's the second best i would
say the world wants two things it wants
crypto property as a savings account and
it wants cryptocurrency as a checking
account and that means that the that the
most popular thing really is going to be
a stable coin dollar
right and it's there's a
maybe a fight right now might be tether
right but
a stable dollar because i feel like the
market
opportunity it's not clear that there'll
be one that will win the class of stable
dollars is probably a one to ten
trillion dollar market easily
i think that in the crypto platform
space ethereum will compete with solana
and finance smart chain and and the like
are there certain characteristics of any
of them that kind of stand out to you
don't you think the competition is based
on a set of features
also so
the set of features that uh that
cryptocurrency provides but also the
community that it provides don't you
think the community matters and sort of
the adoption the dynamic of the adoption
both across the developers and the
internet i'm looking at them i mean the
first question is
is uh what's the regulatory risk how
likely is it to be deemed a property
versus security and the second is
is what's the competitive risk and the
third is what's the speed and the
performance and uh and the
you know all those things
you know lead to the question of what's
the security risk how likely is it to
crash and burn and and how stable or
unstable is it
and then there's the mar you know the
marketing risk i mean there are
different teams behind each of these
things and and communities behind them
i i think that um
the the big cloud looming over the
crypto industry
is regulatory treatment of
cryptocurrencies and regulatory
treatment of crypto securities and
crypto platforms and i think that won't
be determined until the end of the first
biden administration for example um
there are people that would like only
u.s u.s fdic
insured banks to issue cryptocurrencies
they want jp morgan to issue a crypto
dollar backed one to one
but then in the u.s right now we have
circle and we have other companies that
are licensed
entities that are backed by cash and
cash equivalents but they're not fdic
insured banks
there's also a debate in congress about
whether state chartered banks should be
able to issue these things
and then we have
tether and and others that are outside
of the u.s jurisdiction
they're probably not backed by cash and
cash equivalents they're backed by stuff
and we don't know what stuff and then
finally you have
you know ust
and dye which are algorithmic stable
coins
right that are even uh more innovative
further outside the compliance framework
so if you ask who's going to win the
question is really
i don't know will the market decide or
will the regulators decide if the
regulators get out of the way and the
market fought out well then it's an
interesting discussion yeah and then i
think that all bets are off if if the
regulators get more heavy-handed with
this and i think you could have the same
discussion with crypto properties like
like the d5 exchanges and the crypto
exchanges the sec would like to regulate
the crypto exchanges they'd like to
regulate the d5 exchanges that means
they may regulate the crypto platforms
and at what rate and in what fashion
and so i think that
i could give you an opinion if if it was
limited to competition and the current
regulatory regime
but
i think that the regulations are
are so fast moving and it's so uncertain
that it's
it it
you can't make a decision
without considering
uh the potential actions of the
regulators i hope the regulators get out
of the way
can you steal me on the case that
dogecoin is uh i guess the second best
cryptocurrency if you don't consider
bitcoin a cryptocurrency but instead of
crypto property i would classify it as
crypto property because the us dollar is
a currency so unless your crypto asset
is pegged algorithmically or stably to
the value the dollar is not a currency
it's a property or it's an asset
so then can you still man the case that
doshcoin is the best cryptocurrency then
because bitcoin is not even in that list
the debate is going to be whether it's
property or security and there's a
debate whether it's decentralized enough
so let's assume it was decentralized yep
well it's it's increasing at not quite
five what five percent a year inflation
rate but it's it's not five percent
exponentially it's like a plus five
million
five percent something captain is less
i forget the exact number but it's an
inflationary property it's got a lower
inflation rate
than the us dollar
and it's got a much lower inflation rate
than than uh many other fiat currencies
so i think you could say that but don't
you see the power of meme the power of
ideas the power of
uh fun or whatever mechanism is used to
uh
cap captivate a community i do but laura
meme stocks it doesn't absolve you of
your ethical and securities liabilities
if you're you know if you're promoting
it so like like i i don't have a problem
with like people buying a stock
it's just uh
the way i divide the world is right
there's investment there's saving and
there's speculation and there's trading
so bitcoin
is an asset for saving if you want to
save money for a hundred years you don't
really want to take on execution risk
or the like so you're just buying
something to hold forever for for you to
actually endorse something as a property
like if you said to me mike what should
i
buy for the next hundred years i say
well some amount of real estate some
amount of scarce collectibles some
amount of bitcoin right you can run your
company
right
but running your company is an
investment so the savings are properties
if you said what should i invest in i'd
say well here's a list of good companies
private companies you can start your own
company that's an investment
right um
if you said what should i trade
well i'm trading as like a proprietary
thing like i'm i don't i don't have any
special
insight into that if you're a good
trader you know you are if you said to
me what should you speculate in
we talk about meme stocks
and meme coins
and and it's kind of sits up there it
sits right in the same space with what
horse should you bet on and what sports
team should you gamble on and should you
bet on black six times in a row and
double down each time
that's i mean it's fun but
at the end of the day
it's uh it's a speculation
you